I can't either I can't either
so weird
why do you think this
I was just so curious to know what it
would be like to be physical with
someone that you love
because I already knew that
I loved him as a friend Raquel Levis
sharing her side of the story of her
seven month affair with Tom Sandoval
which ended his nine-year relationship
with Ariana Maddox I've never like had
sex like that before I should have like
completely removed myself from the
situation but I did not have the
willpower to not see him on the
Vanderpump Rules season 10 finale
scandaval is officially exposed and what
was once behind the scenes between
Raquel and Tom is now front and center
I love you I love you too
I said they love you oh but I love you
too
I know we always said like we wouldn't
do this if we didn't think it was worth
it just think of it it imploded it's not
this is not ideal at all I know I know
[Music]
the stupidest thing
the two also discuss what to do now that
their Affair is out there Raquel
acknowledges what goes around comes
around am I really
going to put my life on the line
for someone that would cheat on someone
that they love so much because then that
makes me think that you would be capable
of doing that to me I would never do
this if there wasn't something here but
for Tom no matter the outcome he feels
like he's got a new start I can't
predict the future who's to say like
maybe things will work out with Raquel
and I maybe they won't but when I kissed
Raquel I felt hope I felt like wait a
minute your best days aren't behind you
maybe they're just beginning I just feel
like it during so horribly wrong
well things ultimately didn't work out
between the pair ahead of the season 10
finale A source told E.T Raquel and Tom
broke up the magic of this show is the
ups and the Downs unfortunately but the
authenticity of the show that's why
people bled by Ariana because they were
invested in real relationships and
that's what life's about and if you
thought the finale was explosive I don't
give up
just wait till Raquel and Tom come face
to face with Ariana and their co-stars
at the three-part reunion which starts
airing next week on Bravo
I have been super selfish selfish does
not cover it diabolical demented
sub-human poo poo head both of you poo
poo heads James I'm gonna get sent for a
timeout
there was just so much on the table that
needed to be and everyone had things to
say I would say I mean that being said
I've now done you know hundreds of
reunions so yeah I would say this is
going to be this is going to be top ten
you can't think of two worst people I
can't
[Music]